Я дуже сумувала за того що я вижила Бо
мені було дуже тяжко прийняти себе новою
і
я зрозуміла що А от я зараз хочу без
ноги Ну я сиджу і я живу
і я можу там стати піти Да з миличами
Але можу тож щодня вона встає і виходить
на прогулянку рідною Одесою руслані
данилкіній 19 рік тому дівчина вирішила
стати на захист України і добровільно
пішла на фронт я більш боялися за те що
я не знаю куди я їду і на який час Я
покидаю свою домівку от від цього Було
трішки страшно я розуміла що я не знаю
що буде а дуже сильно хотіла бо це моя
країна Я її дуже люблю і я розуміла що
чим нас більше тим тими сильніші і я
розуміла що я не можу зробити щось
велике але я можу
попитатись зробити хоч щось і
думала що хоть мала якась частина ну
допоможе моїй країні і тому я зібрала
речі і поїхала
спочатку у руслані довірили роботу з
документами але вона швидко зрозуміла що
хоче працювати ближче до фронту через
юний вік тоді 18-річній дівчині кілька
разів відмовляли проте завдяки
наполегливості Руслана все-таки
домоглася свого й почала працювати
операторкою з’ясковою щоденна служба
тривала аж до дня Який розділив її життя
на до та після 10 лютого Руслана з
побратимами виконували бойове завдання
на Херсонщині я була як завжди в гарному
настрої все було добре аж раптом почався
артилерійський обстріл уламки касетних
снарядів поцілили у пасажирське сидіння
момент взриву і якось Несвідомо я
сховала голову і потім я дивлюся що я
вже тримаюся за коліно і одразу
зрозуміло що сталося я не хотіла в це
вірити Я питала у побратимів коли
кричали що там
а відповіді Я не
було і якби не медики як і їхали
неподалік і вчасно надали першу допомогу
Руслана могла б загинути від втрати
крові я тоді вже зрозуміла А коли
переклали мене до буса то я вже побачила
що вона газ збоку і все я заплющила очі
і їхала до лікарні ми не там вже
проопрацювали бо в мене була дуже велика
втрата крові і від того мене в той же
день евакуювали до Миколаєва до більш
безпечного місту в Миколаєві пробувала
три доби і вже тоді переїхала до Одеси з
тих пір я думаю що коли я приїхала в
Одесу Мені стало якось морально трошки
легше я ж вдихнула свій рідний своєрідне
місто і з того моменту почала боротися
за своє життя
і продовжує боротися щодня Руслана
перенесла 5 операцій нині проходить
санаторну реабілітацію
знаходжусь на етапі заживлення ноги
перемотую постійно бинтами і вже коли і
знімаю постійно заміри ноги коли вже
вона перестане худнути то тоді вже буде
приступати до протезу
завдяки пожертвам вдалося зібрати понад
70,000 $ на протест для Руслани хотіли
саме отобокс тому що він
багатофункціональний в ньому є все в
ньому можна плавати передвигатися по
піску бігати до довгий час і тому ми
хотіли саме його бо з механічним трошки
незручно і тому прийшли до вирішення
відкрити банку і люди які хотіли
допомагали вдалося зібрати дуже швидко
ми не очікували такого результату
завдяки своїй жазі до життя Руслана
стала одним із символів сили та
незламності Утім втрату своєї ноги
дівчина прийняла не одразу я не можу
сказати точно дату бо це було так що
нібито Ось я прийняла все гаразд Я
звикла до себе я виходжу на вулицю
приходжу до палати і я розумію ні ну
тобто Навіть через три неділі 4 Я
дивлюся там фотографії вийшло на
прогулоню і вона прогулянку брат
фотографувався дивлюсь фотографії ось
навіть недавно і А я би з ноги ну тобто
досі буває таке що я забуваю і це Я
рахую що навіть до сих пір не має от
повного
свідомості що от все
майже два місяці але фантомні
боль Я дуже давно вже відмовилася від
внутрішньом'язових обезболів сама я
прийшла до рішення що треба переставати
їх пити і відчувати ногу як є і тому я
перестала все пити і фантомні болі
вернулися стали більш
болячими А з часом вони почали
притупляться з Я коли почала
бесідувати з психологом вона мені почала
доносити як саме я повинна ну доносити
свого своєму мозгу що ніжки вже немає бо
він пам'ятає мій образ Ну який був
раніше і дає тобі імпульси із-за цього
виникають болючі відчуття
попри всі випробування Руслана хоче
мотивувати інших постраждалих від війни
людей аби вони не втрачали віри в життя
Я хочу жити я хочу показувати людям на
те що це можливо моя сама не така проста
мрія Я хочу стати на коньки і поїхати Я
мрію велосипеді і якщо вони немає ноги
це ж не означає що я Ну все я хочу
показати людям що все можливо і не треба
сидіти і ховатися якщо у вас щось
сталося да це страшно це боляче Але
Життя продовжується його треба жити
[музика]